after New Year everyone hope you're all
well it's New Year's Day here in the UK
and it's pretty cold but I thought I'd
do a quick video just to give you an
update and our plans for 2019 if you're
new in this channel I'm Alex Jen Aikido
Club here in the north of England I also
run this channel which has a lot of
Aikido content but also cross trains
with other martial arts I also have some
flow art videos such as pi and clip
spinning with a bit of travelling thrown
in remember subscribe if you like what
we do and maybe check out some of our
previous videos so what's new for 2019
I'll be doing an analysis of some stuff
sparring videos cross comparing
different types of stuff and seeing if
form translates to sparring I'll also be
looking at some Wing Chun principles and
how they can be applied and hopefully
I'll get right on editing some of my
footage that I've filmed this summer on
a road trip to Russia from the UK to
attend a week-long kadesha there
I also got the opportunity to teach a
class while I was there so we can have a
look at that there's plenty of
interesting footage from the trip but I
still need to wade through it so just
bear with me hopefully I'll get around
to discussing these swords as well
I had them custom made and I'm appliance
workers from Salt spiralling using
Aikido there's also a cross training
seminar plan for spring however we're
still in the other stages of planning so
I'll keep you updated with that get
start quite early this time of year so
come back inside if there's anything
specific that you want us to cover or
they've got any questions leaving the
comments down below if you like what
we've got planned for the new year and
share the video give us a thumbs up and
also remember to hit the notification
button so you've you're made aware when
we were uploading new videos finally I'd
like to thank all subscribers for your
continued support you've really kept me
motivated to produce more content and
we've had a lot of positive feedback so
I really appreciate it anyway that's
about it for now keep your eyes out for
upcoming videos and take care and I wish
all the best for 2019
you